ich freue mich sehr dass sie heute bei
uns sind in unserer Sendung es gibt
einiges zu besprechen beispielsweise
jetzt neue Recherchen aus den USA ja
dort hat sich ein Journalist einem
deutschen Thema gewidmet und meint ganz
klar die Politik aber auch biontech hat
Einfluss genommen auf Twitter das belegt
er mit internen E-Mails die deutlich
machen sollen dass dort Druck gemacht
wurde auf Twitter bestimmte
Veröffentlichungen zu verhindern oder
zumindest zu verstecken das ist eines
unserer Themen hier jetzt bei viertel
nach acht ich freue mich sehr Zara
hältst du das für möglich dass Einfluss
genommen wird wir haben das gesehen in
dieser Krise dass viele Meinungen
kritischer Experten nicht gehört wurden
dass sie auch mundtot gemacht wurden
dass sie diffamiert worden jetzt eine
neue Recherche aus den USA eines
investigativ Journalisten der behauptet
er hat interne E-Mails vorliegen und die
zeigen das biontech ganz klar auch Druck
gemacht hat aus Sorge vor Aktionen
überrascht dich so eine Recherche nicht
überrascht das gar nicht mich wundert
das auch gar nicht ich meine mich
überrascht dass er wenn jetzt jemand
sagt oh damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet
wir hatten wirklich mehrere Jahre der
Pandemie wo man das auch nicht mehr
kritisch sehen wollte wo man das Leben
an die höchste Priorität gesetzt hat und
auch kritische Stimmen ganz bewusst
negiert hat und nicht mehr zugehört hat
und das z.B Bayern Tag ein Unternehmen
ist das Geld verdienen will viel Geld
und auch lobbyiert und auch Druck machen
kann das wurde der Zeit lang vergessen
und äh wollte man wahrscheinlich auch
vergessen und ich denke da werden wir
noch viel mehr davon hören
also auch das ein bisschen mehr Arbeit
jetzt betrieben wird ein bisschen Licht
ins Dunkel zu bringen bisschen
Aufarbeitung
und während der Pandemie nicht getan hat
das ist ja auch interessant die
Journalisten z.B hätten sich ja auch dem
annehmen können während der Pandemie
aber man tut es jetzt eigentlich wo die
Pandemie vorbei ist also zu spät aus
deiner Sicht zu spät aber es muss sein
und jetzt erst recht muss eigentlich
alles aufgearbeitet werden
einige haben es natürlich gemacht der
nicht alle Journalisten haben vor allem
nichts gemacht gleichzeitig kann man
sagen Herr Dr Peters ist das nicht
einfach was ich da jetzt gerade
beschrieben habe Lobbyismus einfach
Globalismus so wie er überall passiert
ja ich denke schon also wo viel Geld zu
verdienen ist passiert sowas natürlich
auch follow the money ist immer die die
die Maßgabe eigentlich in jedem
Gerichtsprozess und auch in jedem
Lobbyismus Prozess also wirklich
überraschen kann das eigentlich nicht
sie hat es nicht überrascht die
Aufarbeitung dennoch auch ein Thema das
jetzt hier in Deutschland immer weiter
hoch kocht viele stellen sich Fragen
fragen sich wie geht es weiter steuern
wir auch dann wieder in die gleichen
Fehler von vorher rein tun wir genug in
Sachen Aufarbeitung
ich fand die ganze Zeit sehr schwer muss
ich sagen ich habe einen Freund der ist
Epidemiologe der stabilitiert des
Professor der hat mich immer gerade
gerückt dann habe ich wieder von anderen
Leuten ganz andere Sachen gehört aber in
diesem Dschungel zurechtzukommen war
glaube ich auch für die Profis extrem
schwer
was vielleicht sehr enttäuschend war ist
dass man nicht so in der ganzen Breite
die Experten angehört hat ich würde mir
vorstellen dass ein Helmut Kohl der
hätte sich die drei vier Protagonisten
die jetzt sehr unterschiedliche Meinung
sind zu sich ins Kanzleramt geholt hätte
gesagt hier ist ein Raum hier ist der
Schlüssel den man jetzt zu ihr habt was
zu trinken aber ihr kommt erst wieder
raus wenn ihr euch geeinigt habt auf
eine Haltung und das hat halt nicht
stattgefunden ist war glaube ich eine
recht einseitige Debatte und die führt
natürlich zu Fehlern wenn Sie das erlebt
hat auch ihrer Umgebung gab es da
kritische Stimmen den man nicht zuhören
wollen es gab kritische sogar liberale
Menschen Künstler die auf der Straße
gegangen sind und waren gegen diese
corona-politik sie wurden alles rechts
abgestempelt obwohl sie alle eigentlich
ideologisch links anzusiedeln waren und
das ist genau es kam eigentlich zu einem
Paradigmenwechsel nach Kohl in der Zeit
von Merkel hatte sie die Leute auch nach
sich
im Kanzleramt geholt hat sie aber nicht
gesagt er muss euch einigen und dann mir
sagen sondern er muss dieses Thema so
annehmen wie ich ist sehr und das wird
jetzt fortgeführt am Thema Corona und am
Thema Migration merkt man dass es eine
große Diskrepanz gibt zwischen dem was
tatsächlich passiert und das was in den
Medien berichtet wird da sind wir auch
gleich bei ihrem Thema da steigen wir
gleich tiefer ein verschieben möchte ich
auch noch einmal zu diesem Thema aber
abholen was hat das mit ihnen gemacht
wir haben ja auch über das Vertrauen
über Aufarbeitung der corona-krise
gesprochen wie blicken sie auf dieses
Thema haben sie Vertrauen ich habe sehr
viel Vertrauen weil es geht hier um das
Bewusstsein dass wir wir sagen sozusagen
Erwachen es ist ja von den
Konstellationen so ich beobachte das ja
aus einer anderen Perspektive und habe
sozusagen einen Abstand den ich in
einnehmen kann also das was ich
wahrnehme was ich sehe und diese Phase
der Aufarbeitung ist jetzt absolut
richtig und zentral weil in der Zeit wo
so viel versteckt wurde wo wir so viel
eben auch online uns überhaupt erstmal
unterhalten haben man darf nicht
vergessen dass wir durch die
corona-phase durch sind in einer in
einer Möglichkeit wo wir überhaupt
erstmal alle online gegangen sind ganz
viele Leute sind plötzlich online
gegangen plötzlich eine ganz viele
Stimmen gehört von Menschen die gutes
gesagt haben Menschen die vielleicht
auch nicht gutes gesagt haben aber diese
Art der Kommunikation das gehört zum
Zeichnen Zwilling ist das Thema gewesen
dieser wie das heißt besonders gut oder
nur Zwillinge am Ende können das wäre
schlecht
die Energie es war ein Fokus auf dieser
Energie für uns alle also globalen und
dass der Journalismus da ins Zentrum
gekommen ist mit Lüge und Wahrheit war
so klar für mich mich hat das vollkommen
ruhig gelassen natürlich auch habe ich
viel beobachtet aber das ist jetzt wo
die Themen sich verschieben da kommen
wir natürlich
zur Aufarbeitung kommt das phänomenal
absolut richtig und sie sagt mir auch
sie haben noch vertrauen ich hoffe das
sehen sie auch so quasi mit ihrem Blick
in die Zukunft über den wir uns auch
gleich noch unterhalten wollen dennoch
muss man sagen dass man sehr sehr viele
ernste Themen dabei Folgen von Lockdown
Menschen die unter der Impfung leiden
oder die unter Ausgrenzung leiden für
wie wichtig glauben sie ist es für die
Menschen dass das alles jetzt in einer
offenen Debatte aufgearbeitet wird
absolut wichtig und so zentral und wir
haben die Möglichkeiten dazu da die die
elektronischen Möglichkeiten sind
gegeben und jetzt braucht es die
Menschen die mutig sind es anzupacken
und die Wahrheit aussprechen ist die
Politik der mutig genug
Politiker wir haben verlangen schon gar
nicht viel wenn Sie das sagen oder
trauen sie es ihnen nicht zu also
schauen Sie die Politik sollte für die
Menschen da sein nicht andersrum und
jetzt nehmen die Menschen dasselbe in
die Hand so dass die Politiker erfahren
werden was es bedeutet wenn die Menschen
Aufstehen das ist der Trend gut das wird
auch der Trend für dieses Jahr sein höre
ich sagen vielleicht sogar die Sterne
absolut und noch da schauen wir gleich
und noch darüber hinaus was heißt
darüber hinaus ich glaube da sprechen
wir nachher drüber
ein weil es mich fasziniert aber sie
haben komplett Recht darüber sprechen
wir danach wir sprechen hier viel in
dieser Sendung über vertrauen wir
sprechen viel über Aufarbeitung und wir
wollen hier vor allem eins wir wollen
eine offene Debatte führen